to follow up on the panel that we just
heard on curators and education we now
have the students who curated the
contemporary art south africa exhibition
and one of the artists mikhail sabotsky
whose work is included in that
exhibition
and i just want to say that these
students have been mentored over the
last year and a half by my colleague
kate ezra who is the nolan curator of
education and academic affairs and kate
heads the gallery's education department
and as such she handles the big picture
of all of the educational work going on
here and she works directly with yale
courses and each semester this is
something that's really very special
about what kate does here at the gallery
each semester she curates the study
gallery and so she's marshaling faculty
requests from every field imaginable
drawing from every area of the
collection and it's remarkable how
semester in and semester out she creates
such a beautiful presentation of those
works from such diverse areas of the
collection
so um i'm going to hand it over to kate
now to introduce the panel
i am so excited to be here i don't i
hope i don't embarrass myself anymore
um and i'm so glad that the students
will have an opportunity to
talk about their work with you
there were so many um
thoughts and ideas that came up came up
in the previous
panel about curating and student
involvement and training the next
generation of curators that i'm i'm sure
there will be um ideas that will
go resonate but the the uh focus on
hands-on learning and the primacy of of
prince because there are so many prints
in the exhibition that the students
worked on
the idea of really looking
that dabney was talking about
the idea of pushing boundaries these
students
thought a lot about boundaries and and
how to push them or blur them or
work within them
so our panel will be a case study of one
of several exhibitions at the yale
university art gallery in recent years
that have been collaboratively curated
by a group of undergraduate and graduate
students there have been eight of these
exhibitions since pamela frank's
inaugurated the program in 2006 and one
more is in the works and will open this
fall
each one of these exhibitions has shown
that giving students the responsibility
for actually creating an exhibition that
will be viewed by the public
deepens the students learning and at the
same time has much to teach those of us
who have the pleasure of working with
them
the exhibition contemporary art south
africa opened yesterday and i hope many
of you had the opportunity to see the
exhibition and attend the tours
for this panel we have six of the
students who participated and one of the
artists
last spring i selected this group of
students and charged them with creating
an exhibition on contemporary art in
south africa using a small
group of works that were already in the
galleries collection as a starting point
i had already gotten permission for this
student curator team to borrow works
from a few other local
collections which is not a common
feature of our student curated shows and
was a real privilege for us
the rest of the work was up to the
students
they had to decide which artists and
which works to include what themes or
ideas to focus on what type of
information to include on the labels and
in the brochure and many other aspects
of curating and curating an exhibition
having spent more than a year on this
project meeting every week over three
semesters
the students have deeply engaged with
the subject of the exhibition and with
the museum itself
and with many of my colleagues here who
i thank deeply for all the time that
they have spent working with the
students
this panel will be an opportunity for
the students to reflect on their on the
process and what they will take away
from this experience and bring with them
into the next stage of their lives
but before we begin i'd like to
introduce them to you
from left to right
so on the far left is christina
christina wells who is a phd candidate
in the department of african american
studies and sociology with a certificate
in women's gender and sexual sexuality
studies
her dissertation focuses on black
atlantic contemporary art collectives
and seeks to situate the present moment
within a longer history of black
artistic production
for the past four years christina has
worked as a wordle gallery teacher
teaching the k-12 classes that visit the
gallery
next to christina wells is christina
vernicole who will graduate next week
with a ba in history of art
she's also a practicing artist and has
worked for the past three years as a
gallery guide here at the gallery giving
thematic tours to adult visitors
christina has organized several
exhibitions of yale student artists work
and this summer she will be working for
david's werner gallery in new york
next is catherine kalin who is a junior
at yale and will graduate next year with
a ba in english
she is a student guide at the yale
center for british art and has
participated in two student curated
exhibitions there across the street in
addition to working here on contemporary
art south africa
claire schwartz just finished her second
year as a phd student in african
american studies and american studies
her research concerns the intersections
between poetry and contemporary black
atlantic art and i am sure that at least
a few of the artists in our exhibition
will play a role in her research and
writing
as an undergraduate at williams college
claire traveled to south africa to look
at innovative conceptions of
institutional memory as as exemplified
by the district 6 museum and after
graduation she spent eight months in
cape town on a williams college
postgraduate research fellowship it was
a huge boon to this project that four of
the seven students had previously
studied or done research in south africa
in the center is mikhail sabatsky seated
among the students he is
the artist whose wonderful film moses
and griffith is included in the
exhibition
i hope many of you had the chance to see
the film last night during our evening
of conversations and performances
michael received his his bfa from the
michaela school of fine art at the
university of cape town in 2004
and he has since achieved international
acclaim for his photographs which
combined the directness of social
commentary while questioning the nature
of the photographic medium itself
mikhail's work can be found in the
collection of the museum of modern art
in new york the south african national
gallery in cape town and the
johannesburg art gallery as well as
other museums in europe and the united
states
his photographs have been included in
many international exhibitions and
mikhail has already received numerous
awards including the 2012
standard bank young artist of the year
award for visual arts which is the
highest honor for a young south african
artist
he also received a similar award from
the international center for photography
in new york and he has been inducted
into the prestigious prestigious magnum
photo agency
michaela's here in new haven to
supervise the installation of moses and
griffiths in our exhibition and we
thought it would be a wonderful
opportunity if you could also
participate on the panel not only as an
artist who is naturally concerned with
how his art is curated and presented in
exhibitions but also because moses and
griffith is itself so concerned with the
presentation of information and
knowledge within institutions like
museums which is the underlying premise
of this whole conference
next to mikhail is katie fine who will
graduate from yale next week with a ba
in history although she has taken many
courses in the history of art
for the past three years katie has
worked as a gallery guide here at the
yale art gallery giving both highlights
and and thematic tours
and she's studied abroad in south africa
during her junior year at the university
of cape town and she's looking towards a
career in museum education and will be
attending the harvard school of
education in the fall
finally denise lim will receive her m.a
in african studies next week and will be
continuing on at yale as a phd student
student in sociology next year
as an africanist she's interested in
cultural and artistic production in
south africa
and how that interacts with historical
and contemporary politics
her research focuses on cultural
sociological approaches to anglophone
african and south african literature in
particular
she spent a semester in south africa as
an undergraduate and returned last
summer for her thesis research
matthew keaney is the one student who's
not able to take part in today's panel
and he is a phd student in history also
focusing on south africa
you can see that the diversity of
disciplinary backgrounds and approaches
that the students brought to the project
and this diversity was crucial to the
development of the exhibition and added
so many layers of meaning to the
discussions and ultimately made it a
much more complex and more subtle
exhibition
so i'm going to take my seat and
then we will unpack the curatorial
experience for these students
so
thank you again for
being a part of this wonderful panel for
this wonderful conference
so i want to start off by asking you as
a group you have so many different
backgrounds and so many different levels
of experience both with south africa and
with contemporary art
so how did you grapple as a group
with the charge that you were given to
assemble an exhibition of contemporary
art from south africa
um
i can try to respond to that first um
i think for me coming from an african
studies background especially my entry
point was my interest in south africa
and south african cultural production
i was very
concerned
that we would be careful about the way
that we're representing south africa
first of all
to a foreign audience especially in this
particular context
and because i wasn't sure how much sort
of text could be provided to
provide some historical context to
south africa's sort of very difficult
past
i also was interested in the way that
art could communicate
certain information that you couldn't
otherwise
in the textual way
and i also found that even though i
wasn't as familiar with visual art a lot
of the debates that were going on among
south african writers
were kind of the same questions that
were going on among visual artists as
well so questions about identity gets
very difficult in a country that is
quite
diverse there's a lot of different kind
of social groups that exist
whether by linguistic lines or
racially stratified lines
different ethnic groups that were sort
of formed um i also was uh concerned
that we wouldn't um give an impression
that south africa sort of this this one
thing um only plagued by sort of an
apartheid history i think we really
wanted to be able to be
to touch base with that history but not
also not have the art that we choose be
consumed by it
so in the beginning we were reconciling
our different disciplinary backgrounds
in the interest of defining these key
terms for denise it was so helpful to
have
this substantial background in african
literature and specifically south
african literature we went about
defining south africa it was also quite
a difficult challenge to define
contemporary art and to define
contemporary art from south africa and
we all wielded different sort of
strengths in that in that process of
defining these key terms and as you'll
see in our title and in the exhibition
if you go have a chance to visit
that those definitions and that process
of grappling with that charge really
informed the end result
i think it was immensely helpful that we
were
charged with contemporary south african
art and it actually turned out to take
pretty much the whole process grappling
with what these terms meant and then
sort of the invisible fourth component i
guess would be
to think about what the role of the
institution is what the role of the yale
art gallery is and presenting these
narratives so it wasn't really
south africa that we were drawing from
it was actually south african art in the
tri-state area
so to kind of i mean to kind of really
think about to take seriously what the
institutional collecting practices look
like and to think not only about
presenting south african art from the
vantage point of looking at south africa
20 years after the formal transition to
democracy
but also
looking at ourselves looking at that um
yeah
can you um
say a little bit about how all of this
these discussions and the grappling with
these different terms and and ideas led
you to the idea of the slash and what
the slash is for people who have not
seen the beautiful
title wall or the brochure that
incorporates it
sure
um so we settled on a title of
contemporary art slash south africa
as i said it is a very much a visual
embodiment of the reconciling of those
two distinct entities
and we spent a lot of time thinking
about the qualities of distinction and
categorization specifically in south
african history
both on the side of racial
categorization and the very problematic
history that race presents in the
context of south africa as well as the
distinct boundary drawn between the
apartheid era and the post-apartheid
area era delineated by nelson mandela's
election in 1994. um and those
boundaries we felt were being called
into question by a lot of the artists
and the work that they were putting out
and we hoped that in our in our
exhibition we would retain some of that
sense of blurring boundaries and
sort of
troubling categories that are typically
understood as distinct
by placing that at the foreground
and and
further uh troubling the distinction
between a nation and the art it produces
and so in our exhibition we hope to
present individual artists and
individual artworks
in a way that is
very compelling to all viewers and at
the same time present a complex portrait
of south africa today through this lens
of blurring boundaries and overturning
categories
sure i'll pipe up now um i also think
that the slash enabled us um i guess
rewind 30 seconds one of our concerns in
this exhibition was presenting um
south africa or the contemporary art
produced in south africa in terms of
absolutes
and going back to claire's comment of
looking at ourselves looking at this art
we are a group of seven students three
undergrads four graduate students um i
was the baby of the group um both in
terms of age and in terms of
terms of knowing things about the
contemporary south african art scene
um and i think we the slash enabled us
to present these works of art not in
terms of absolutes um and enabled
the exhibit to produce a conversation
rather than us imposing a definitive
thesis statement upon it
so
did you want to follow up i wanted to
add that it was important to us
not to
present the exhibition as a survey
the hope is not for viewers to come away
feeling like once i've stepped foot in
this space i've learned all there is to
know about contemporary south african
art thank you very much good night
but rather to enter
uh into a number of worlds into a number
of um
art
making practices through a number of
different sort of categories that we've
put up and i think that the work with
graphics
really helped to push that idea and if
you'll go up to the exhibition you'll
see that
rather than delineating spaces in the
exhibition by
one section text that represents all of
this work um we decided instead to
include section text that sort of
referred to all of the works so that you
can mine the collection and mine the
exhibition a number of different ways
you can go back
a number of times and see the works in
conversation with one another based on
very different
vantage points so that was another kind
of solution to some of the challenges
that we
faced and in that same vein the
exhibition itself the layout of the work
is extremely open uh we tried not to
cordon off any particular areas or
create specific groups within our works
going back to this notion of blurring
boundaries there's a lot of space for
the viewer in terms of eye line was
something that we had many discussions
about
in our curatorial process
i want to ask mikhail
how do you as an artist from south
africa feel about
seeing your work contextualized in in
this kind of an exhibition
that focuses on
contemporary work from south africa as
opposed to being in an exhibition of
contemporary art generally or an
exhibition of the entire african
continent or some other subset of
contemporary art what does it mean for
you to be in an exhibition like this
thank you um
before i answer that i do want to
congratulate the curators and yourself
kate um i think it's a very very
coherent and interesting presentation of
contemporary south african art and um
one that i wanted to be a part of so
thank you for that
um
what you're raising is is difficult for
me as a as a young-ish south african
artist
um
uh
i
i've been a part of a number of kind of
survey shows both of south african art
and
african art from across the continent
and you always do get the feeling that
as interesting as the exhibition might
be you are being put in a little bit of
a basket just
in the same way as uh photographic
surveys might do in another respect to
my work
um but i also understand that uh
every exhibition needs
its limitations and sometimes
nationality or
geography is an important starting point
for that
i think
in
in south africa
we have a heavy burden of particular
lines of thought
and
kind of themes within our artistic
production and
i think uh the important thing is to
is to as an artist from an artist's
perspective is that one doesn't get
weighed down by by how heavy those those
things are historically
um themes of identity themes of politics
and demonstration and and so yeah i
appreciate the fact that this exhibition
has not um
uh
gone in in predictable ways on those
lines
thank you
as student curators for many of us it
was our first curating experience and we
came to this idea of blurring boundaries
before we knew how it would manifest in
the final exhibition stage and so to
make all of this real we relied on a lot
of expertise in the rest of the
gallery's community and in the obviously
with kate's mentorship but also from
different departments i think that was
maybe one of the most
exciting aspects of being a student
curator
was the the combination of
bringing
insightful and new and fresh and kind of
uh
perhaps uncuratory ideas
and seeing those manifest with gallery
expertise in the interests of putting
together this exhibition that we're very
proud of
so
i know we're all so pleased with the way
the exhibition looks now and the way
it's it's turned out but i know from
having been part of the weekly meetings
that there were several challenges and
pressure points
so
differences of opinion and lots of
discussion
so i'm wondering what did you find most
challenging about this project
what were some of those issues that you
needed to
discuss and overcome and resolve
so i think to begin with the tech coming
from a technical standpoint uh one of
the most challenging uh dimensions of
this process for me
was not being able to see the work in
person per se we did actually borrow
a great deal from outside of the
institution i think one of the most
helpful
points in retrospect was being able to
see the core works of the of the actual
yale art gallery collection um in person
and to be able to
have engaged discussions about these
works and then sort of expand on that
framework that was already in place for
us
um for me coming from an artist
background uh process is very important
for me and always my entry point to a
work of art
so really one of the most i mean this
probably goes without saying but it was
incredibly rewarding to be up
in the gallery during the installation
process and actually see these things
brought out of their packaging
and finally get a sense of what it means
to actually paint with ash
which is one of the works that we have
from diane victor called ashman johnny
um and you know it's all incredibly cool
to talk about in theory but then when
you actually see it in person you
understand
what kind how our ideas that our
exhibition is shaped around is actually
conveyed in in that process and in that
specific work of art
i think one of the really
i think one of the really amazing things
about this opportunity was kind of going
into a blind in a way i mean i had
really approached the museum as a museum
goer up until this point so i didn't
really think about a lot of the
kind of logistical issues that you run
up against as i mentioned we were
fortunate enough to be able to borrow
but our borrowing was constricted in a
certain way
and so i think as mikhail was saying
there are
limitations to any coherent exhibition
but
something that was really challenging
for me was to make those limitations and
their stakes known um so
i mean one thing just really concretely
that came up is we have a lot of william
kintridge's work in the exhibition
so to think about what really kentridge
has meant
and what it means that we have so much
can george work
and maybe other artists are less
represented because of that
those have raised really generative
challenges about collecting practices
and the moment that we're at now
i think another exceptional set of
circumstances that we were delightfully
dealt with was the fact that at the end
of the day we were are we seven or were
we eight there were seven seven student
curators um four graduate students three
undergrads all entering from different
points of interest
starting with different knowledge bases
um so i think one of the other big not
so technical difficulties that we had to
overcome was we all had to get ourselves
to a uniform baseline level of knowledge
to a certain extent um which was a
really exciting process we had
bibliographies felt a little bit like a
class for the first three months um and
then once we were able to get to that
point we were able to have the
conversations that led us to the
exhibition as it is now
mikhail you were about to say something
yeah i want to jump in here and kind of
answer a question that hasn't been asked
of me but um claire mentioning um
william kendrick um
made it urgent um
so so it's it's been very interesting
for me to um sit in on i haven't managed
to catch all the conference sessions but
particularly this afternoon i was
sitting in and listening and i got such
a sense of um
or maybe i brought with me a sense of
perspective and
and i'd like to kind of try and describe
this to you with regards to
continuity and discontinuity
for me the very idea of having such an
amazing art museum on a campus and have
defining it
at least partially in terms of being a
teaching institution
is this
incredible vision of continuity and it's
a continuity that comes from an
incredible luxury of resources
and i know it might not be fashionable
to talk about a luxury of resources
in america and economic climate right
now but it really does strike me and i
think it's something that's really
really important to think about both in
a positive and then perhaps also in a
challenging way and i'll get in a moment
how this relates to the things being
discussed
um but um
spending my whole life in south africa
being born and growing up in south
africa we have
a very strange kind of combination of
resources and lack of resources i was
very lucky to get a very good university
education um and and through my career
to have access to a lot of resources um
but there's this unbelievable
discontinuity between for instance the
university and the commercial art
galleries and then the kind of gaping
hole of the public institutions which
don't perform the function that they
should
perform in creating continuity between
those different organizations so the
fact that you guys are all here having
this conversation about how to kind of
um
link different disciplines link
different departments link the schools
and the uni and the museums um
it it is really amazing and inspiring
and part of me wants to say um can you
can you share some of that with us
um but another part of me thought about
a little bit deeper and thought about
what the challenge of discontinuity
brings to artists and curators and
scholars in south africa
and um
i i guess i'm bringing this into the
conversation because i think that
there's something that can be very
strong that can be learned from there
what are strategies um
by artists by curators to make up for
the lack of continuity between
institutions
um and if i have a criticism of this
process is that
perhaps
you guys haven't learned enough about
those survival strategies because i
think those come in very much into into
artistic practice in south africa for
instance one of our better known
curators now um gabriel noble is part of
an organization called the the center
for historical reenactments which is you
know a collective put together by
artists and curators um and um
so um
for us that that that is educational you
know that those are institutions which
we're being forced to make and while i
think the the um the incredible
resources that everybody here has within
their institutions is something that
should never be wished away i think
there's a lot that you can learn from us
in kind of
in finding new strategies for the new
ages of of of what our survival
strategies are
and um
yeah i came to all of that really
through through through kentridge who is
is really a great hero of mine a great
inspiration to a lot of south africans
um but it is also you know
a reflection on resources that cantridge
is is the starting point of this
exhibition it's you know greatly um
uh hit the respect for him and his work
is is absolutely earned and amazing but
um it is it uh yeah it is a question of
resources and i think that should be
thought about
yeah i was just going to say that that
raises a really interesting issue
because we actually
debated a lot about
historically and even now sort of the
axis of opportunities for different
artists
of very different backgrounds
so even though in one sense in the
united states kentridge has sort of
heard about but not necessarily to the
extent that we might have thought he is
and of course we recognize the the
quality of his work as an artist
but again trying to grapple uh with sort
of the racial politics or identity
politics that goes on i think especially
when you're talking about south african
art um and i think what was interesting
for us was that we had this opportunity
to um incorporate art from a lot of
different media
and so we had one gallerist who
suggested why don't you look into video
art
because this allows for south african
artists who are in the country but
haven't been exhibited outside
to have this opportunity to be exhibited
here
and that to me i had never really
considered that before i was also not
very familiar with video art before
coming to this project but i felt like
this was a very interesting way to
at least alert the public to very
interesting artists that aren't normally
circulated at least in the united states
and so on on one hand you had our
limitations of only being able to borrow
from the tri-state area so these are
sort of south african artists that are
somewhat well-known enough to make it
over here
but then having to balance that again
with ones that are maybe not as well
known here but wanting to give that
opportunity to them so um yeah i think
those are very interesting points that
you raised because i think we we as a
group tried our best to at least think
about that within the limitations that
we had
i think another challenge that we faced
is
the university setting in and of itself
and us being so intimately connected to
it as a phd student as someone who's
sort of
inundated with discourse and a certain
way of thinking and writing having to
translate that to
uh in my writing in the way that i
approach curators and discuss the works
and the ideas behind it
all of this critical thinking had to be
filtered in a way
to continue that accessibility to
continue making the ideas that we are
thinking about accessible to a number of
audiences
so that was definitely a challenge
as tiffany sprague
sort of alluded to in her question for
the last panel
how to help students become better
writers but also how to help sort of
lofty thinkers
bring their ideas home
in a very clear and effective way and so
that was a challenge but also a
fantastic opportunity as someone who's
also looking to continue in museum
education that's something that is going
to absolutely carry me through and i
also wanted to add that our disparate
sort of backgrounds and interests i
think will also help the curatorial
world to expand its pipeline from just
the history of art to include folks like
us who may not have phds in that
discipline but who are getting
first-hand experience so i think the
university setting has provided a huge
challenge but also
a great opportunity for all of us
that's great i think um
i know the label writing was a challenge
during the process and there were many
iterations and every curator no matter
whether they're a student or they've
been working for 25 years in the field
goes through all those
drafts and i have to say you all nailed
it so
good job
um
well now that you can see the exhibition
up on the walls and that if you've been
in the galleries as you have been you've
seen people reading your your your wall
text you've seen people um looking at
the brochure and watching the videos and
and looking at the at the at the works
of art what is it that you as curators
hope that people are going to really
take away from the exhibition what's
what's your ultimate goal
or is there another question you'd
rather answer
well on one level i certainly hope that
visitors remember individual works of
art we spent so much time with these
works of art over the course of the last
year and a bit um
in reproduction and in person um that we
came to know them so well that it's so
it's somewhat hard for me to imagine
what a visitor who's seeing the
exhibition today must be experiencing
because for most of these visitors this
art and these artists are are largely
unknown
and now that we've come to know them i
can say firsthand that they are
incredibly compelling works of art that
are applicable not only to the context
of south africa but absolutely in this
context and in all contexts
so i think the first thing is is
meaningful experiences with the
individual works of art
and after that uh hopefully the uh
the question of what it means to be an
artist in contemporary south africa
is illuminating not only for uh south
african cultural production but also
broader on the on the contemporary
global scale
of issues that are relevant in
contemporary life and
specific broadly
yeah and i hope that people are
pleasantly surprised by what they learn
um
again sometimes i think when when people
think of african art they might think of
sort of stereotypical images and
for us it's it's a really special
opportunity to be able to focus on a
specific african country
and also link that to the contemporary
art world
that to me is a very sort of special
combination
which is why i think we tried to take
care not to do it badly
we really wanted to make sure that if if
we're going to frame things in a
national framework which can be
problematic in itself at least let's
raise some questions so i think we
really had to
to force ourselves to really think
through in a deep deep way what is our
theme because we are really struggling
with finding one because we don't want
to put this whole thing in a box
so even coming up with the three
sub-themes that we had
art and politics personal and social
here and there
we kept debating well should we create
sections that are along these lines
but i'm really happy with how how we
ended up with
wanting our visitors to think about all
of these different themes
and pairs or how they are boundaries or
or they can cross over
how each work can really embody a lot of
different themes simultaneously
so i think we were we are asking our
visitors to do a little bit of the work
you know um we tried our best within the
details of the way that we um placed all
the objects um the what the places that
we chose to put the text um even
arrangement um and how we group certain
works i mean i think we tried our best
to sort of guide um that kind of
engagement or thought on the on the part
of the visitors
i think one thing that i hope as
christina mentioned this is not a survey
and i would hope that people who are
coming at least with an eye toward
creating exhibitions would really think
about the way that our exhibit
and others before it have put pressure
on the idea of a survey that something
can be comprehensive or representative
in itself and that's really something
that we took from the art itself which
is making use of these categories
because as we've acknowledged they're
important for legibility but also being
really self-conscious about the
production of boundaries and the stakes
of those production
and mikhail i have one one question for
you and then i'd like to open it up for
the
conference attendees to ask questions
so when we first contacted you
and i explained that it was a student
curated exhibition
what was your reaction did it matter did
it was it
was it did it make the project more
interesting or less interesting or how
is an artist do you feel about being
involved in a project that is
so based in bringing students into the
process
it was a yale student curated
there's a very personal response is that
um
i i kind of um
i kind of wish i was a student still um
i uh i did a undergrad uh
major in fine art at uct and
um
have been
deprived of the opportunity of doing an
mfa by being very busy
um and a huge part of me um
still wants to do one
and um
can you introduce me um so uh
but but the spirit of being um in an
educational institution is is i think a
great privilege and one that i kind of
i'm constantly feeling like i want to be
a part of and whether it's you know i
teach kind of part-time in south africa
really for my for myself because i
really enjoy it and learn so much
so
that really wasn't the thought of mine
you know whether it was curated by
students or
people from different different
disciplines um it sounded like an
interesting presentation and i wanted to
engage with it
and we're so glad that you did
so now i'd like to see if anyone in the
audience has questions i see many hands
and the microphones are rushing
hi thank you that's such a great project
i was wondering
i'm very interested in what we've been
talking about today sort of teaching
curators teaching the next generation of
curators and as a teacher
i'm interested in the ways that you as
students
change our practice
and uh so i'm curious if you could
comment a little bit more on
how
this is how a student-curated show is
different from
a show that's curated by an
institutional curator
and what that can teach us and what that
also tells us about teaching curators
well maybe i should answer that or
christina you're you look like you're
about to answer that i mean you can
definitely respond what
no i was just gonna say that uh one
thing that really shocked me with this
process was um the vast amount of nuts
and bolts that goes into being a curator
um and i think as students this has sort
of been commented on in previous panels
the generation that we're from we're
constantly trying to speed up that
process
and so i think in ways kate was
excellent in making us slow down
and really think very carefully through
each step of the process but in other
ways it was quite advantageous uh the
position we were coming from uh one sort
of basic example of that would be the
fact that when we were playing with
which works we would like to select we
created a flickr account i don't know if
that's something that curators would
normally do in an institution
as it was quite public
and we use the groups within that
technological platform web-based
platform um to play with our own
personal selections and then merging
those selections on a large screen
and it was a great way to start with you
know i don't know how many works we
started with a hundred many many more
and bring it down to the to what you see
in the gallery space right now
that's a perfect example of how the
students approach the project
differently than i think a curator would
and i think just the fact that there's
seven there were seven of you and you
all came from such different starting
points and different vantage points
that it's
that added uh a huge layer of complexity
to the project that a single curator
working alone with their own ideas um
uh does not does not grapple with and i
think it it really made your work in a
way harder but it also made it much
richer that you that you worked as a
team
i'm michael i'm michael taylor i'm the
hood museum at dartmouth college and uh
i was so impressed by the exhibition
because it really
looked like an exhibition it didn't look
like a student exhibition it had real
graphics it was presented beautifully
and selected very well and you're right
it wasn't a survey
my question has to do with so you
mentioned the nuts and bolts of
exhibitions and it seems like the focus
for you was selection
and also label riding and i'm wondering
were there other aspects of the
exhibition that you're also involved
with i'm wondering if you were involved
with the press release with the martian
campaign and could you speak about that
side of it
and the installation
so uh
programming
yes to all of those things
denise and i wrote the press release we
worked of course with members of the
gallery staff but yes we did that
absolutely with the installation we were
up in the galleries in all the free time
we had it was coincided unfortunately
with finals period
but we worked as best we could to have
student curators present at least some
of us in as much as we could um worked
directly with the art handlers worked
when we heard from them from moma that
we could not put the works in in a space
that had too much sunlight we were
absolutely involved in relocating that
to a different wall
all of those all of those challenges we
faced and and all of those
opportunities we embraced um unfortunate
rhyme
and in terms of programming i'll turn it
over to
perhaps either claire or christina who
were very involved in that aspect of the
project
um yeah we also were involved in
programming and that's actually
something that we're trying to work out
now but again
it really came out of the conversations
that we've had and i think we've
foregrounded the selection process
because we were charged with working
around this particular body of works and
so much of the theme the way that we
were inspired to arrange the exhibition
came out of really the work
so in terms of programming we've invited
i don't know what i'm allowed to say
because we haven't had confirmations
we're in the process but um we're hoping
to invite curators artists um and also
to involve visual arts as and um i mean
sorry also to involve um literary arts
as well and kind of expand the
conversation
can't get too much into specifics
hi
um i just want to oh my name is amelia
klm from the hood i'm in the back
um i just want to say i really enjoyed
your exhibition and i noticed that uh
in a few instances you have the same
artist with multiple examples of that
artist's work and you've chosen not to
hang those together which
struck me as very intentional and
perhaps slightly unusual i wondered if
you could talk about that decision
making process why include multiple
works and why not put them together
anyone want to
explain the why the four cartridges are
mostly not together and
gary schneider's work is not together
but cedric nunn's work is all grouped
together and sure um so in some
instances it was purely logistics um for
example the cantridge anamorphic
projection
required a very specific space and we
had to accommodate that
but once we were kind of given those
logistic challenges and and realize what
that would mean for our exhibition we we
really did embrace that
and we chose to to intermingle as much
as possible the individual artists
in some cases some artists have
works that are either from a series or
are closely related in those cases they
are shown together because we treated
them as
consistent within one theme
but on the
more broadly speaking
we hoped to
increase the sort of connections that
were drawn between artists and between
different media and between different
artworks i'm including art from
different decades even
so that the the theme of of boundaries
and crossings and typically understood
distinctions would be further overturned
and that new conversations would be
inspired
john
hi um hi john steinberg from mount
holyoke college art museum
first of all i think you guys knocked it
out of the park uh really it's a great
show um and my question is i'm very
interested in group curating and the
dynamics of group curating um i'm a big
proponent but i was wondering now that
you have all tried it uh what did what
do you think would you do it again are
you looking hopefully to curate your
next show by yourself
well chris
i i would absolutely
uh do this again and again and again if
i had the opportunity um working with
with my fellow curators was such a
pleasure and such a privilege
it's absolutely
changed the direction of my career i
hope
my dissertation my life here on campus
i know that it's not typically done in
the curatorial world for a number of
reasons many of which we've you know
discussed today the challenges of group
work having to come to consensus dealing
with different
levels of
knowledge
and interest and positions in politics
even
but i think that it's an invaluable
experience and i'm not sure if you're
looking for like the
dirty details
of the of the arguments that we had but
even those were so generative
i feel just personally on a really
concrete level it forced me to clarify
my own positions really productively i
mean i think at the later stages or
often when you're faced with having to
explain yourself but just coming once or
twice a week for three semesters and
having to really justify and advocate
for what you believe is crucial and
really ultimately served the exhibition
yeah i never want to curate an exhibit
by myself
for your great contribution um so you
have two descriptors of the exhibition
it's south african and it's contemporary
but i'm wondering uh
if
and if so what the role of race played
in terms of your object selection
okay
sorry that's always the hardest question
for me um
yeah i think we were quite conscious to
try to be as diverse in our selection as
possible i mean on one hand we wanted to
first select based upon the the work
itself and what attracted us most
and that was actually for me something
that i felt was a very valuable learning
experience because i didn't come from
sort of this art history side or even
the fine arts side
so actually i feel like what i've
learned the most is just to fall in love
with art
but then yes of course because of my
particular background
very concerned about issues of you know
colonial gays or the politics of
representation and so um
that definitely came into play after we
had like a certain set of works that we
really loved um and then thinking about
the stories behind each of these artists
because i think
we've come to know these works almost
like people
i think even for us seeing our own show
now and seeing it all up after the
decisions and the fights we had
advocating for certain ones to be in or
in the end i think we really feel that
we know these works
we
we really appreciate the artists
themselves we appreciate their process
the final product
it helps if you know something about
sort of the south african context but
it's not necessary for you to really
appreciate what's there before you um so
i think it really it really operates on
a lot of different levels i wouldn't say
race was like kind of the the sole thing
that made us pick a certain artist it's
certainly part of it
and we have to be sensitive to that but
at the same time we have to balance that
uh
yeah balance sort of the appreciation
for art itself
yeah i think also for me as someone who
teaches from the collections as a
gallery teacher and has done so for the
last four years that's a really
important question that we should ask of
all the work that's in any museum it's
not a question that should be
you know
central just to south africa or
essentially just to contemporary art but
when we're in front of a beer shot when
we're in front of rosco when we're in
front of any number of works that we
teach from how do we
not impose those questions but
sort of bring out the nuances that those
questions
would suggest so that was definitely
a point that we discussed but also
within a larger context of
the museum and the works that other
visitors are going to see before and
after encountering this exhibition
and how can we be a part of that
conversation how can we continue that
conversation and not have it just start
and end on the fourth floor
and in terms of just to add one quick
thing in terms of
the sort of ratios within the show or
the artists themselves we were very much
focused on the works
specifically and how the work spoke to
us
beyond the racial identity of
of the artists who produce them although
quite often that was a big you know
stake within that work of art
hi
hi my name is yuchana and i'm a graduate
student at the university of texas at
austin and i'm really curious about how
your group came together and what the
process was in terms of how you were
selected did you apply and i've heard
mention of three semesters so i'm
wondering how that worked out and
meeting once a week i'm just wondering
about the format of
the process of curating the show like
did you get credit you know all those
kind of details thank you
so i'll just
i'll just start off by um
saying that
when we got the go-ahead to do this show
and we knew when the
the dates would be
i sent out a call for
applications for participation i sent
emails to all the undergrads and grads
in history of art
school of art
african american studies african studies
and
i think that was
that was those were the departments that
i targeted and all and also to the
galleries gallery guides and gallery
teachers
and i got maybe about 15 or 20
responses and i interviewed and talked
with people and
um felt that the seven that i selected
really brought a range of perspectives
and experiences and
really showed the interest and
commitment to the project that was
sometime in the
early spring of 2013 and we started to
meet in spring semester
the students don't get any
academic credit for this it's a
completely extracurricular
activity for the students it's really
their passion their love their their
interest that drives it
um we broke for the summer which we had
just built up the momentum of forming
the group and then we broke for the for
the summer break and then we got back
together and had to pick up that
momentum
in fall of 2013
um and maybe they can talk about how the
group actually came together how did
i selected you but you you formed a
group
we have some more group performing to do
no we're we're it's been such a pleasure
to work in this group but it did it did
require a lot of um getting comfortable
with one another in a way that we could
be honest about our our ideas and our
preferences and our priorities for the
exhibition and that we could reconcile
our different disciplinary backgrounds
and and wield those differences in the
interest of a very productive uh and and
complete effort um the summer break was
was difficult but um it was okay because
we met and we did site visits in new
york and we saw artwork in galleries and
museums and then we corresponded the
entire time by by email and sometimes by
phone i think one of the other
challenges that now that we're talking
about logistics that came up was
actually fitting in meeting times to our
very busy course schedules i mean
because we're seven students you can
imagine we don't all take classes at the
same time um so we had to to meet um to
schedule meetings whenever we could find
that spare time um so that was an
additional logistical challenge uh but
we i think we came beyond it
yeah i think we would definitely
advocate for you know the the use of
digital technology certainly um i live
in new york and oftentimes it was a
skype meeting
it was via flickr there were emails
there were google docs so that we could
all sort of collaborate together so to
speak to someone's point earlier about
how to leverage those those media
it was absolutely crucial for creating
that cohesion when scheduling and
facetime wasn't always an option
is there time for one more yes sure one
one last question hi i'm kathleen
bickford-burzock from the block museum
at northwestern
i want to congratulate you also on a
really terrific exhibition
uh i'm interested in hearing from the
students about what the experience has
been like of meeting
mikhail and working with him seeing his
process in installing a really
challenging work of art
and how that has sort of been a
culmination
of this experience and what
you i mean what a great privilege it was
really to have him be able to come and
work on this and for you all to meet him
and
wonder if anybody wants to comment on
that
yeah um
i mean absolutely it's been a huge
privilege and i think that um
i mean just to his first of all it's an
immensely complicated piece to install
um it's a four channel video projection
so i think just sort of
seeing the work that goes into something
that looks seamless at the end is
is quite rewarding in itself also he's
just been really generous and
speaking to us about our whole process
but yeah thank you
and just to expand your question we've
also had the privilege of meeting robin
road who was here earlier in the year
and may come up for the exhibition at
some point
his work is
in the first gallery the video
installation it's fantastic and it's in
the center fold of our brochure we've
corresponded with gary schneider as well
so there have been a number of artists
who we've been able to communicate with
to work with to really understand their
intention behind their work
and also to get a better sense of the
landscape of contemporary south african
art first hand and that's just been
invaluable
for for a group that isn't able to
travel to south africa
and there may be more artists in the
future but we are not at liberty to
discuss
well i think that's a wonderful um point
to end with and um
gets back to the importance of the work
and and the importance of the artists um
in creating that work and that's the
basis of what we build upon so i just
want to thank the students again for all
their work
and before you all get up
oh my
goodness wow
thanks very much
first of all i want to thank the
students for such an interesting panel i
did catch the
second half of it uh up there and
you're doing fantastic work uh before uh
before you go off across the street for
reception i just wanted to welcome you i
know it's a little late for a welcome
this is the life of university president
but and just say two words
to you
first of all
i feel so lucky
to be in a university with the kinds of
art collections that this university has
across the street in the center for
british art here at the yale university
art gallery we feel incredibly
privileged
and we feel incredibly privileged
really because all of this is here for
our students when i was dean of yale
college which
was the case some years ago
i used to
welcome students by encouraging them to
go
to the center for british art and the a
university art gallery and i would say
to them why do you think we have
these wonderful collections of art at
yale
and they would say to me
things like well
i guess it's a really nice thing that
yale does for the new haven community
and i would say well you know be a
little more selfish think really think
about why university idea would have
such wonderful collections of art
and they would say
okay well
we got it when our parents visit it
gives our parents
and i'd say try again
and they and they would say and finally
they would say well maybe it's here for
us right and i'd say yes it's here for
you
and then we would talk about not just
how wonderful it is to walk over to
gallery and see beautiful things
or even to take an art history course
let's say and learn more about the
history of art and then get to actually
see what they're studying all that is
great by the way but the thing that
excites me the most is the way in which
we teach through collections in all
kinds of subjects that might not
immediately be obviously about art
and so when i used to teach the
introductory psychology course
one of the things i occasionally would
do
is give them an assignment like think
about
the way in which people in a certain
place and a certain time
understood what it meant to be insane
right it's a psychology course right
and i would say go over to the art
gallery and see if you can find
something that helps you understand
that question
i didn't mean the staff
i meant something hanging on a wall
and and they would often find something
interesting about you know about a
representation of something in medical
science or something in psychology or
just something that they would project
their own
uh psychology on to but they would they
would come back with some interesting
things then i used to in class
occasionally show them a series of
of van gogh self portraits and we would
do a kind of try to figure out what was
going on in van gogh's mind uh at these
different
uh
stages of his of his own life anyway the
whole point of this is not
uh is not about psychology but about the
integration
of art and a wonderful set of
collections in in teaching and i i think
for me that's what this is all about now
as a psychologist i also have another
interest
uh in in orp
and that is what what my lab has studied
for
now about 25 years is emotional
intelligence and emotional intelligence
is the idea that we have a set of skills
that help us function in the world
uh that are
only slightly related to our
intellectual capacities
uh but that have to do with
understanding our emotions understanding
them
identifying them
in ourselves and other people managing
them in ourselves and other people and
then most importantly using them to
motivate ourselves to make decisions to
solve problems to do something creative
and people ask me all the time well all
right if those are important skills how
do you how do you get better
and we would talk a lot about well one
of the things that adults can do
young adults in college or later is get
involved in the arts as a way of honing
their skills of perception and their
skills of inference and their ability to
kind of read things you know broadly
speaking their ability to interpret them
and i think most of you know we do that
with our medical students
here
but everybody can improve these
emotional intelligence skills by looking
at
great pictures
um
so you know for me it's
not that we have these wonderful
collections that are great to offer to
the community but of course i'm
delighted that that's the case
it's not that we have these great
collections that we can offer to parents
of students when they come and visit for
parents weekend but i'm delighted that's
the case
it's really that we have these great
collections that we can integrate in all
kinds of interesting ways it's almost
anything that they're learning anywhere
in the curriculum just takes a little
imagination
the last thing i'll mention just to say
i think our newest our latest um
creation in this world is actually out
on the west campus this is the old bayer
pharmaceutical uh plant uh r d facility
that we purchased some years ago a few
years ago
and out on that in that facility or is
first of all some browsable storage for
parts of the collection
uh particularly this side of the street
and as well as the peabody museum
but next to that uh
storage facility is something called
uh the institute for the preservation of
cultural heritage
and what i like about this is
it is several
kind of e
broadly speaking it has several
different things all
uh co-located all literally right next
door to each other
with this great uh
uh
collection storage right next to it it's
two different chemistry labs
working on the preservation working on
issues really concerned with the
preservation of materials over time
whether it's pigments
or plastics
or tapestries or what have you how do
these things
change in response to climate and
weather and indoor and outdoor
and then next to them
is
one of the great art
conservators ian mcclure
work actually working on paintings and
next to that is i might not have them in
exactly the right order but
nearby is a digitization facility
looking at ways of making the
collections more accessible to greater
array of
people and next to that is stefan simone
pulling all of this together creating
educational programs
and although i think his original
background is on the chemistry side
very enmeshed on the art side as well
and thinking about some of the policy
issues you know
like who owns the elgin marbles or
should ya'll have given machu the hiram
bingo machu picchu collection back to
the peruvians or you know these are
these are fascinating questions so i
love
the idea
that we've got in one place
chemists uh art conservators
digitizing professionals from sort of a
seatt with computer science background
uh um
educators and
people were thinking a little bit about
policy
and so so from from science
to practice
science humanities and arts all next
each that's what universities should be
all
about and i love the fact that we can
use art
as the bridging
mechanism between the sciences and
humanities so i you know those of you
who are older
and remember for example the essay that
c.p snow wrote on the two culture
problems sort of arguing and predicting
that universities are going to be torn
apart
by the fact that science and arts don't
understand each other
not only do they understand each other
on this campus they're working together
in this example in on on very important
projects that i think are really not
happening on any other university campus
but this one anyway i hope you have a
lot of time to browse around uh the art
gallery browse around the center for
british art uh enjoy the great work that
jack and amy have done and the great
curatorial staff and student curatorial
staff that we have here at this
university we're so proud of it i can't
imagine any place i'd rather be
especially for these issues and i'm so
glad you're here to share it with us
thanks very much for being here
so peter i want to thank you very much
for coming and i just want to tell
everyone here one of the great
privileges of working at this university
is we have had the leaders of this
university for as long as i've been here
deeply deeply committed to supporting
these teaching museums and what it is we
do and that's certainly the case with
peter his wife marta you can see he
shows up here at the end i've got to
tell you what his day was like he i
won't bother
to to share this with you his wife
martha was just at our governing board
dinner and there's been a long tradition
of the leadership of the youth of this
university coming in literally to meet
with our board our curators our students
on a regular basis and not only that
what you need to know about this guy
he's the member of a bluegrass band
and the name of the bluegrass band is
the professors of bluegrass and their
latest cd which you've got to go out and
buy is
pick or perish
and i can tell you this is the only
major university president in the world
who played in his own band at his
inauguration he plays a very good base
so uh we just feel wonderfully fortunate
to be able to convene this incredible
conference peter it's 350
colleagues from universities all in
colleges all over america and abroad and
there's been a tradition of these
gatherings before what we've done and
they're going to continue on and we've
just had this spectacular presentation
that goes to the heart of what it is to
be a teaching museum with these students
who are so very proud of so thank you
for spending time with us thank you
you